[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
مرتقبه للرئيس السابق الثلاثاء قبل ساعات
من محاكمته
تشكيل الحرس الوطني في اسرائيل
يرى النور رغم معارضه الاغلبيه
حتى نهايه العام لدعم استقرار السوق
ولدينا ايضا
تفقد علامه التوثيق بالامتناع عن الدفع
وائل ماسك يهاجمها
[موسيقى]
عواصف قويه تجتاح الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه منذ ايام ادت الى مقتل 20 شخصا
واصابه العشرات لكن هناك عاصفه اخرى
العاصفه
التي تلاحق الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
ترامب بات اول رئيس امريكي توجه له
اتهامات جنائيه بسبب دفعه 130 الف دولار
لممثله الافلام الاباحيه ستورمي دانييلز
مقابل صمتها عن علاقه مزعومه بينهما سيمثل
امام المحكمه بعد ظهر يوم الثلاثاء المقبل
في يوم ينتظر الجميع معرفه ماذا سيحدث فيه
طبعا ينفي ترامب الاتهامات ويتحدث عن
اجراءات مسيسه وعن اضطهاد سياسي اما
ستوربي دانيلز فقالت انها باتت تشعر لاول
مره بالخوف دانييلز اوضحت لصحيفه تايمز
انها تلقت سيلا من الاساءات والتهديدات في
غضون ساعات من صدور لائحه الاتهام ضد
ترامب دانييلز كان من المفترض ان تظهر على
قناه توب تي في البريطانيه لاجراء مقابله
حصريه يوم الجمعه الماضي لكن المذيع
بيرسموغن كتب على حسابه في تويتر انها
اضطرت الى تاجيل المقابله قبل دقائق من
عقدها لاسباب امنيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
محامي الرئيس الامريكي السابق ترامب خرج
متوقعا ان تسقط لائحه الاتهام ضد ترامب
لكنه شدد في الوقت ذاته بالقول مستعدون
للمعركه
انه يستعد للمعركه وما يحدث من الواضح انه
اضطهاد سياسي واظن ان الناس يعتقدون ذلك
انها اساءه استخدام كامله للسلطه انه رجل
قوي وهو شخص سيكون مستعدا لهذه المعركه
نحن كذلك مستعد وانا اتطلع للعمل على
تبرئته باسرع وقت
وفي الوقت الذي اعلن فيه ترامب انه سيتحدث
الثلاثاء من فلوريدا قبل محاكمته في
نيويورك تتاهب شرطه نيويورك بنشر سته
وثلاثين الف شرطي وتسعه عشر الف مدني على
الطرق العامه لمده اسبوع بحسب مصادر شبكه
ام بي سي وكشف المتحدث باسم شرطه نيويورك
ان تاهب الشرطه ياتي استعدادا للرد على اي
تجاوزات قد تحدث
يوم الثلاثاء الموعد المرتقب لمصول الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه في
نيويورك وحملته كشفت عن بعض التفاصيل وفقا
لحمله دونالد ترامب للانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله يخطط ترامب للسفر الى نيويورك بعد
توجيه اتهام له من قبل هيئه محلفين كبرى
في منهاتا حسبما كشفت الحمله سيقضي الرئيس
الامريكي السابق عطله نهايه الاسبوع في
مره لاغو ومن المتوقع ان يحافظ على جدوله
المعتاد في منتصف نهار الاثنين من المقرر
ان يسافر ترامب الى نيويورك عبر طائرته
الخاصه على ان يقضي الليله في شقته في برج
ترامب في منهات قبل التوجه للمحكمه بحسب
تقرير لشبكه سي ان ان فقد يتم تاجيل
القضايا الاخرى المقرر عقدها امام محكمه
من هاته الجنائيه يوم الثلاثاء ومن
المتوقع ان يتم توجيه الاتهام الى ترامب
في الساعه الثانيه والربع بعد الظهر
بتوقيت شرق الولايات المتحده او السادسه
والربع مساء بتوقيت جرينتش محامي ترامب
انه لن يتم وضعه الاصفاد في يدي الرئيس
الامريكي سابق وعلى ان يطلق سراحه بعد
توجيه الاتهام اليه وان يعود الى فلوريدا
في الاثناء لا تزال تفاصيل تهم التي
واجهتها هيئه المحلفين الكبرى لترامب سريه
الا ان مصادر قالت لسي ان ان ترامب يواجه
اكثر من 30 تهمه تتعلق بالاحتيال التجاري
اما في جانب تحضيرات الحمله الانتخابيه
فمن المتوقع ان يعود ترامب لاستئنافها يوم
الاربعاء
رده فعل الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب كانت حديثه من حوله فكيف كان وقع
لائحه الاتهام الجنائيه على ترامب
منهم من قال بان ترامب كان منزعجا وغاضبا
ومصدوما ومن هم من قال بانه ظل هادئا جدا
ورزينا وفقا لواشنطن بوست
الرئيس الامريكي السابق بحسب مصادر مقربه
تبلغ الخبر بمكالمه هاتفيه ثم بدا بالتحرك
اتصالات بالجمهوريين في الكونغرس ووعود
بالمحاربه حتى البراءه والدفع بالمظلوميه
الرئيس الامريكي السابق سيمثل امام محكمه
منهات يوم الثلاثاء القادم قبل ان يضطر
للوقوف امام قاض للاستماع الى التهم
الجنائيه الموجهه اليه تحت حمايه امنيه
مشدده وسط توقعات من احد مستشاريه بان
يظهر الرئيس السابق دقيقا وحذرا خاصه وان
هذه تعد سابقه سياسيه وتاريخيه قد يستفيد
منها ترامب كثيرا ويستغلها في حملته
الانتخابيه للعام 2024
عندما يسلم ترامب نفسه سيتم حجزه في
الغالب مثل اي شخص اخر يواجه التهم ستؤخذ
بصماته من دون تقييد يديه ربما وسيتمتع
بحمايه الخدمه السريه ومن شبه المؤكد انه
سيطلق سراحه في اليوم نفسه
الفريق القانوني الترامب وفريق حملته
امضوا اسابيع في التحضير لصدور لائحه
الاتهام ضده بحثوا خلالها خطه الهجوم
باستخدام ورقه الدوافع السياسيه ضد مدعي
عام مقاطعه منهات ومحاميه السابق وهو احد
الشهود الرئيسيين في القضيه
ونداءات لجمع التبرعات والحلفاء
القانونيين والسياسيين والاعلاميين
الرئيس السابق
طبعا اهم شيء هو قبل ان نجيب على هذا
الموضوع لنعرف الخارطه السياسيه وبالتالي
بامكاننا ان نجيب على هذا السؤال هنالك
ثلاثه مراحل ثلاثه ساحات الساحه الاساسيه
هي السياسيه وهذا لا شك فيه نظرا لمشارع
بالخمس سنوات الماضيه الثانيه هي اعلاميه
المعركه الاعلاميه هي مهمه جدا لانها تقع
بالنصف بمنتصف الحمله الانتخابيه الثالثه
هي قانونيه بحته اذا سؤالكم هو على
الموضوع القانوني البحري ربما حتى على
السياسه الاعلامي ما اخطر ما يواجهه بمعنى
نقاط قوته ونقاط ضعفه مقابل اداء الاخرين
الحزب الديمقراطي مثلا على الاقل
هذا يرتبط بكيف ستسير الامور على الصعيد
القضائي بسرعه لانتقل الى موضوع الاعلامي
وهو الاهم بتقدير والسياسي هنالك اجتهاد
لم ينتبه له الكثيرون ولكن سنسمع عنه ربما
في الاسبوع القادم وما بعد ذلك من قبل
المحامين جهاد دستوري في الولايات انه اذا
توصل هذا هكذا السياسي اي سياسي الى موقع
اي الذي يمثل رسميا احد الحزبين الاساسيين
لانه في احد الامريكيه هنالك حسبان
اساسيان ومرشحه عندها من الممكن انه
المحاكم اذا كان عندها هذا هذا وجهه النظر
ان تقول انا ساجمد القضيه حتى انتهاء
الانتخابات وهذا الاجتهاد ننفذه هنا لدول
اخرى يعني هنالك كثير من الحالات من من
دعاوى ضد رؤساء او مرشحين في دول اخرى
قالت المحاكم الامريكيه كانت في فرجينيا
في كاليفورنيا انه اذا كان ممثلا اخي
نهائيا في المرحله الذي حصل انه الادعاء
في نيويورك حاول ان يستبق هذه العمليات
ترامب الان هو مرشح رئاسي ولكنه ليس بعد
المرشح الرسمي بعد
المؤتمرات هنا ثلاثه اربعه اشهر مهمه جدا
اذا لم يتمكن الادعاء من نيويورك في
نيويورك ان يجمده ان يكبره سياسيا وليس
فعليا فحدود ترامب قد تكون اكبر واوسع اما
اذا نجح بسبب من او لاخر لانه ليست هي
فعلا القضيه الاقوى هنالك القضايا اخطر
بكثير على الصعيد الاداري المالي عندها
سوف نرى ونعيد التقييم لهذا الموضوع وهنا
ياتي دور الجانبين السياسي والاعلامي كما
تحدثت قبل قليل دكتور ولكن على صعيد
الاداء القضائي هناك تصريح لوزير العدل
الامريكي السابق نتابعه قبل ان نعود اليه
لو تكرمت فوزير العدل الامريكي سابق
بالبار اشار الى ان مدعي عاما هاتن اساء
استخدام السلطه وان رائحه الاتهام ضد
ترامب ضعيفه وجاءت لخدمه مصالح سياسيه
دايمون الان من الواضح انه ليست لدينا
لائحه الاتهام وهناك بعض التكهنات ولكن
استنادا للتقارير الاخباريه اذا كانت
دقيقه فهذا امر مقيت هذه اساءه استخدام
لسلطه الادعاء ورفع لقضيه لن يتم تقديمها
ضد اي شخص اخر هم يلاحقون الرجل والنظريه
القانونيه للقضيه بصراحه ضعيفه بشكل مثير
للشفقه
الى واشنطن مره اخرى مع الدكتور وليد فارس
تعليقك على ما ذكره من الجانب القضائي
وزير العدل الامريكي السابق والى اي مدى
قضائيا يمكن ان نعتبر بان هناك صف مرصوص
خلف ترامب يمكن ان ينقذوا على الصعيد
القضائي
زائدا نقاط قوته الاعلاميه والسياسيه
المعروفه
المعركه الاعلاميه هي
نفسها السياسيه الماضيه منذ خمسه سنوات
كما كما شاركنا في هذا الحديث بالماضي
الاكثريه الاكثريه هي مع اليسار او مع بيض
او مع المعسكر الذي هو ضد ترامب هذا سوف
يستمر ولكن الذي يجري على الارض في الوسط
خاصه
دائما مستقلين ينزعجون اكان يمينا او
يسارا ان يتم اعتقال او ان يتم اي شيء
بحرق شخصيه من هذا الحجم الكبير يعني حتى
بموضوع نيكسون كما نتذكر حاولوا لفلفتها
وانهاء الموضوع مع انه كانت منفتحه مفتوحه
الى خيارات قضائيه كبيره
يعني انه الوضع الاعلامي سوف ينجح في وضع
ضغط كبير على قاعده ترامب ولكن هنالك ساحه
اخرى هي ساحه الورده الفعل النفسيه
سايكولوجيكول للقاعده الترابيه لا اتكلم
عن الذين يتظاهرون بالاعلام والى ما هنالك
ولكن على موضوع التصويت وكما قال ايلون
ماسك وهو ليس لاترامبي ولا بيتنه هو قال
انه هذه فيها مخاطره كبيره من ان تتم هكذا
هكذا هكذا ملف قانوني لانه اذا لم يثبت
المدعي في نيويوركا مئه بالمئه سوف يكون
ترامب نجاح كبير في الانتخابات ليس الان
ولكن في العام
اذا شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور وليد فارس
البحث في السياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه من
واشنطن تحياتي اليك
في العربيه 360 ايضا
بالمساعدات الضخمه التي انهالت عليه هل
بات الجيش الاوكراني واحدا من اقوى جيوش
العالم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد وافقت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اليوم على انشاء الحرس الوطني
بناء على مقترح من وزير الامن القوميه
وقررت الحكومه تشكيل لجنه برئاسه مدير عام
وزاره الامن الوطني على ان تقدم توصياتها
في غضون شهرين بشان تقاسم الصلاحيات بين
الحرس الوطني والشرطه ومن المقرر ان يتم
اقتطاع واحد فاصل خمسه من الوزارات اي من
ميزانياتها طبعا اي 300 مليون دولار وهو
مبلغ التمويل السنوي للحرس الوطني
وعلى خلفيه موافقه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
على تشكيل الحرس الوطني وصف زعيم المعارضه
تشكيل الجديد بانه ميليشيا وجيش خاص من
السفاحين
وافقت الحكومه على تخفيضات لتمويل
ميليشيات سوف يقتطعون من ميزانيه الصحه
والتعليم والامن وكل ذلك لتمويل جيش خاص
من السفاحين لمتطرف مهووس اولويات هذه
الحكومه سخيفه وحقيره الشيء الوحيد الذي
يبقيها مشغوله هو تجاوز الديمقراطيه
وتعزيز الاوهام المتطرفه للاشخاص
المهووسين
ليست المعارضه فقط التي ترفض هذا القرار
وزراء بالحكومه ايضا اعربوا عن رفضهم
لتشكيل الحرس الوطني لكن صوتوا لصالحه في
نهايه الامر بحسب مصادر اسرائيليه هذا
الرفض انضم اليه المستشار القضائيه
للحكومه الاسرائيليه جالي بهراف نيارا
التي حذرت الى او من عوائق قانونيه تحول
دون التشكيل وان الشرطه بامكانها التعامل
مع المعضلات الامنيه دون الحاجه الى تشكيل
جديد هذه التصريحات وبحسب القناه الثانيه
عشره الاسرائيليه جعلت نتنياهو يهاجمها
خلال اجتماع الحكومه ووصفها بانها معارضه
مغرضه الرافضون كثر رئيس جهاز المخابرات
الداخليه الشباك
ومفتش عام الشرطه الاسرائيليه يعقوب شفتاي
حذر ايضا من تبعات تشكيل الحرس الوطني
الحرس الوطني الاسرائيلي جدل مدون في
الاوساط السياسيه
ميليشيات مسلحه ام نظام امني جديد
لم يرد نور بعد لكنه اثار حفيظه معارضين
[موسيقى]
قوه مسلحه تمنح صلاحيات امنيه
تعدادهما بين 1800 الى 2500 عنصر تكلفته
300 مليون دولار سنويا
يراسه وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي
ايتامار بن غفير
المستشاره القضائيه للحكومه عارضت انشاء
الحرس ووصفته بغير القانوني
مفوض الشرطه الاسرائيلي حذر من تداعياته
الخطيره
بن غفير لم يخدم في الجيش ولا خلفيه امنيه
له
ادين بالارهاب في محكمه اسرائيليه
لانتمائه الى حزب متطرف
من القدس عبر الدكتور مصري او استاد
العلوم السياسيه في الجامعه العبريه اهلا
بك دكتور لماذا تشكيل الحرس الوطني
دكتور تسمعني نعم اسمعك لماذا تشكيل حرس
وطني لماذا هو موجود كفكره اصلا ولماذا
توافق عليه الحكومه
على الاستضافه استاذي الكريم تحياتي لك
ولجميع من يشاهدنا هو في الواقع تاتي هذه
الخطوه في عمليه تفوضيه بين الكود من
ناحيه
وقائمه الصهيونيه الدينيه التي يتزعمها
والتي ينتمي اليها السيد
والهدف هو بمنتهى البساطه ان يكون هناك
قوه شرطيه او مساعده للشرطه خاضعه بشكل
مباشر للوزير حيث انه الشرطه لا تنصع الى
ليست تحت ابرته وانما تحت ابره قائد
الشرطه وفقا للاعراف المتابعه في اسرائيل
يحاول ان
يغير ويعدل من توجه الشرطه وطبعا هذا لم
ينجح فيه حتى الان وبالتالي لجا الى هذه
هذا المسلك ووفق عليه نتنياهو الذي له
خيار له ولانه اذا رفض ذلك فسقطت الحكومه
وبالتالي هذا ولكن الى اين ياخذ اسرائيل
مثل هكذا توجه يتبناه ويعني يدفع به ويجبر
الحكومه ككل على تبنيه سياسي اسرائيلي
متطرف
لا شك في ذلك لا شك في ذلك اولا هو شخص
متطرف للغايه واضافه الى تطرفه
وسوابقه حيث انه سجن في سابق على خلفيه
الانتماء الى منظمه ارهابيه وكذلك حرض على
اغتيال الراحل رئيس الوزراء الراحه لاسحاق
رابيل قبل ان يقتال وبعد ذلك سجن كذلك مره
اخرى
وحقق معه في حققت معه الشرطه 54 مره وبسبب
خلفيته المتطرفه لم يخدم بالجيش جيش لفظه
كما انه لفظ اسمه قائد الحزب الذي ينتمي
اليه او القائمه التي ينتمي اليه بالاحرى
لانهم التحالف احزاب في اطار قائمه
الصهيونيه الدينيه وبالتالي اضافه الى
تطرف القائمه والوزير اضافه الى ذلك ليست
هناك مؤهلات مؤهلات الحد الادنى من
المؤهلات التي تسمح له بان
يتراس اذا لم ينقلب كل ذلك اصلا على
نتنياهو نفسه الذي اجبر يبدو على تبني ذلك
هذه المره وهذا
محذر منه تصريح المقبل دكتور تبقى معنا
للتعليق عليه بعد قليل لو تكرمت نتوقف
ايضا مع تصريح موشي كرادي الذي قاد الشرطه
بين 2004 2007 وحذر نتنياهو من ان بن جزير
قد يستخدم الحرس الوطني
الذي يقترحه لتنفيذ انقلاب ضد الحكومه
ودعا نتنياهو للتعلم من دروس التاريخ لكنه
حذر من شيء اخر ايضا وهو تشكيل الحرس
الوطني انه قد يكون كارثيا حيث يمكن ان
تتلقى الشرطه والحرس الوطني المقترح اوامر
متضاربه للتعامل مع المتظاهرين
تحذير قائد الشرطه السابق الذي تابعناه
وتحذير المعارضه حول كون الحرس الوطني
ميليشيا خاصه يؤكده هذا المقطع القديم
تحديدا عام 94 عندما سئل بن جزير على سؤال
هل سترفع انت واصدقائك السلاح بوجه الجنود
الاسرائيليين ان تم تفكيك المستوطنات
دعونا نتابع
[موسيقى]
سنستعمل كل ادواتنا كي لا يتم تفكيك
المستوطنه هل يتضمن ذلك اراقه الدماء
سنستخدم كل الطرق الممكنه بما فيها اراقه
الدماء والقتل سنعمل كل ما يمكن لعدم
تفكيك المستوطنات
اذا تم تفكيك المستوطنات في الخليه او
الضفه الغربيه هل سترفع انت واصدقائك
السلاح بوجه الجنود الاسرائيليين
اعتقد انه حاله تفكيك مستوطنات الخليل
وغزه ستتم اراقه الدماء القانون اليهودي
يقر ان الضفه الغربيه وغزه ارض اسرائيليه
ونحن لن نسمح لتيار يسار خائن في الحكومه
بتفكيك المستوطنات
نعود الى دكتور مصري دكتور يعني سالتك قبل
قليل عن
المرحله التي ستشهدها اسرائيل على اثر
تبني مثل هذا المقترح قد يبدو تشكيلا
عاديا ولكن قد يدخل اسرائيل في
متاهه كبرى قد لا تعرف كيف تخرج منها ان
عرفت كيف دخلتها
حديث عن اقتتال داخلي سمعناه كثيرا في
الاونه الاخيره ولم يعد بعيدا بالنسبه الى
البعض مع مثل هذه الاصوات ما رايك اولا
تعليقا على ذلك وهل من اصوات حكيمه بين
قوسين في اسرائيل اليوم تواجه قادره على
مواجهه هذه الاصوات
المساله اصوات حكيمه واصوات غير حكيمه
المساله مساله شرعيه هناك شرعيه في الدوله
هناك مستشار قضائي للحكومه والمستشار
القضائي بالحكومه هو يسمى مستشار ولكنه في
الواقع مراقب هو مراقب يراقب سلوك الحكومه
وقرارات التي تنظر عن الحكومه
ودستوريتها وتوائمه مع القانون والمستشاره
القضائيه للحكومه قالت بانه هذا هذه
الخطوه هي خطوه غير دستوريه غير دستوريه
بالمره وطبعا عوض على المعارضه ليست فقط
المعارضه النيابيه وانما المعارضه لهذه
الخطوات يجب ان نفرق بين المعارضه
النيابيه يتراسها السيد لبيد وسيد جانس
ومن ناحيه ومن ناحيه اخرى المعارضه لهذه
الاجراءات التي تحتوي على عناصر لكوديه
هناك وزراء سابقين للكود بل نواب كنيسه
محسوبين على اليكود هم يعرضون كل هذه
الخطوات رغم انهم ينتمون الى الاغلبيه اذا
المساله فقط مساله معارضه نيابيه ولها
مساله معارضه لهذه الاجراءات التي هي
اجراءات غير قانونيه قبل كل شيء هناك اولا
النهجه المتطرفه المتبع ثانيا عدم دستوريه
هذه الخطوات ثالثا محاوله تدين مؤسسات
الدوله انتم في تقرير
لفت انتباهي كلمه القانون اليهودي ما يعني
ماذا تعنيه في دوله كلمه القانون اليهودي
في الاسرائيلي ليس شيء هناك شيء يعرف
القانون الاسرائيلي على انه قانون يهودي
هو يتعدد عن الشريعه الشريعه اليهوديه
وبالتالي انت تنتقد توصيف القانون اليهودي
الذي استخدمناه يعني
حكومات اسرائيليه متعاقبه تطالب
الفلسطينيين والعرب بالاعتراف باليهوديه
الدوله وانت تعترض على كلمه قانون يهودي
في اسرائيل
تتحدث عن دوله عربيه دوله تركيا الدوله
يهوديه الدوله وقانون القوميه في لا علاقه
لذلك بدي على الاطلاق وانما الهويه
القوميه كلغه اللغه العبريه
التقويم العبري لكن لا علاقه بين هذا
وشريع اليهوديه لم يكن هذه التفسيرات
واضحه من قبلكم في ذلك الوقت كانت اهداف
ذلك الموضوع واضحه عموما ليس هذا موضوعنا
موضوع التظاهرات موضوع التظاهرات هل
باعتقادك هي التي ستحسم الموضوع هل الشارع
سيكون له الكلمه الفصل من الان فصاعدا
لا شكر في ذلك لانه اغلب الاس
رائيلين هم هناك
ايضا في الدوله العربي الكريم
اسرائيل تقتصر فقط على الشعب اليهودي او
على المكون اليهودي هناك الى المعارضه
كبيره وحتى داخل البيت اليهودي هناك
اغلبيه كاسحه للعلمانيين حتى داخل حزب
الليكود وهم لا يقبله حقيقه مصر هذه
الخطوات هو يحاول ان يمرر
واصدقائي يحاولوا ان يمرروا هذا المشروع
لانه مؤقت مؤقت لانه هناك ضغط كبير على
الشرطه وعلى القوى الامن بسبب الارهاب ليس
تعرض له اسرائيل وبالتالي هو لكن طبعا نحن
نعرف نحن خبراء للاسف الشديد في الشرق
الاوسط لمثل هذه الظواهر انشاء ميليشيات
او اجهزه خارج اطار الاطار المتعارف عليه
سواء شرطي او او عسكري فيما بعد من الصعب
ان تحل للاسف الشديد مثل هذه الاجهزه
والسلاح من الممكن كذلك ان يكون من الصعب
السيطره عليه وبالتالي انا اعتقد ان اعول
كثيرا على المعادله المعارضه الشعبيه ولكن
اهم المواضيع الشعبيه هي اطار الشرعيه انا
اعتقد انه هذه الخطوه هي خطوه غير دستوريه
وسوف انا اكتفي معك بهذا القدر دكتور شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه معنا الليله
دكتور مصري استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
الجامعه العبريه
[موسيقى]
نفت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه الضلوع في تفجير
احد المقاهي في سان بيترسبورغ وكانت سلطات
الروسيه قد اعلنت في وقت سابق ان التفجير
استهدف المراسل الحربي التابع لقوات فاجنر
وهو فلادلين
واشارت الى ان التفجير تم عبر زرع عبوه
ناسفه في تمثال سلمه احد الحاضرين حيث
اقيمت حفله للمراسل الحربي في المقهى
ويعتبر فلادين تتارسكي احد ابرز المدونين
المدافعين عن العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا احد ابرز المدونين عنها ايضا
مساعدات ضخمه منذ بدايه الحرب ادت لتقويه
الجيش الاوكراني على المدى الطويل حتى رغم
الخسائر الضابط الاسترالي المتقاعد اعتبر
ان اوكرانيا ربما لديها افضل جيش في
العالم الان بسبب خبره الجنود الميدانيه
خلال الثلاثه عشر شهرا الماضيه مجله
نيوزويك نقلت عن باحث في معهد روكينج قوله
ان القوات الاوكرانيه تزداد قوه كل اسبوع
مع بنائها خبره قتاليه متواصله اضاف
الباحث ان جيوش الولايات المتحده والصين
وبريطانيا لا تحصل على التجربه نفسها لعدم
مشاركتها في قتال مثل ذلك دائر بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا منذ اندلاع الحرب في
فبراير من العام الماضي شهدت القوات
المسلحه لاوكرانيا تغييرات كبيره وبعدما
كان الجيش مسلحا باسلحه تعود الى الحقبه
السوفييتيه بات تتصل لاوكرانيا احدث
الاسلحه الغربيه من دبابات وصواريخ وغيرها
لكن رغم هذه الاعتبارات يبقى حجم القوات
المسلحه لدوله ما احد الاعتبارات المهمه
ووفقا للبيانات التي نشرتها مؤسسه
ستاتيستا للبيانات في فبراير كان لدى
روسيا ما يقدر بواحد فاصل 31 مليون شخص
مدرج في القوائم العسكريه مقارنه بخمس مئه
الف في اوكرانيا من بين هذه الارقام كان
لدى روسيا
831 الف جنديا في الخدمه بينما كان لدى
اوكرانيا
الف جندي وايضا كان لدى كلا البلدين قوه
احتياطيه
قوامها 250 الف شخص
[موسيقى]
وجهه نظري هي ان الاوكرانيين هم على
الارجح افضل جيش في العالم في الوقت
الحالي ليس من المحتمل بل هم افضل جيش في
العالم هو الجيش الاكثر خبره في الحروب
الحديثه واظهر ذلك في الاشهر الثلاثه عشر
الماضيه خسر الكثير من الدماء والشباب
والشابات لتعلم الدروس التي تعلموها لديهم
افضل جيش في العالم وهناك الكثير الذي
يمكننا جميعا تعلمه منهم
وفي العربيه 360
تماشيا مع الخطه التشغيليه لرئاسه شؤون
الحرمين روبوتات لخدمه ضيوف الرحمه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مباشره الى نصر الطيبي
ومعه اخبار الاقتصاد والاهم اليوم طبعا
تخفيض دول في اوبك بلس انتاجها النفطي حتى
نهايه العام لدعم استقرار السوق طوعيا
ناصر اريد ان اسالك بدايه عن يعني فهمك
لهذا القرار الان
بشكله بتوقيته ومضمونه شكله مهم للغايه
طاهر لانه في خلال 12 دقيقه سمعنا اعلانات
متتاليه من ثماني دول ضمن مجموعه اوبك بلس
فرادى عن تخفيضات انتاج طوعيه يصل اجمال
الانتاج الى اكثر من مليون و660 الف برميل
يوميا من الان وحتى نهايه هذا العام وهذا
طبعا يشمل روسيا وسنتحدث اكثر عن التوقيت
خلال هذه الفقره شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اذا في اثنتي عشره
دقيقه ثماني دول من اوبك بلس تعلن عن
سلسله تخفيضات طوعيه في الانتاج حيث قادت
السعوديه خفضا توعيا منسقا للانتاج النفطي
من دول داخل اوبك وخارجها ليضاف لها تمديد
روسيا لخفضها المعلن سابقا ليصل اجمالي
الخفض الى مليون
و660 الف برميل يوميا بدءا من مطلع مايو
المقبل وحتى نهايه العام الجاري التفاصيل
في هذا التقرير
قادت السعوديه خفضا طوعيا منسقا للانتاج
النفطي من دول داخل اوبيك ومن خارجها
باجمالي مليون و660 الف برميل يوميا بدءا
من مايو المقبل وحتى نهايه العام الجاري
وفسرت الخطوه بانها اجراء احترازي لتحقيق
الاستقرار والتوازن في اسواق الخام وفي
التفاصيل ستخفض السعوديه انتاجها من النفط
ب 500 الف برميل يوميا فيما ستخفض
الامارات الانتاج ب 144 الف برميل يوميا
والكويت ب128 الف برميل يوميا كما اعلنت
الجزائر خفضا طوعيا بثمانيه واربعين الف
برميل يوميا كذلك اعلن العراق انه سيخفض
الانتاج ب 211,000 برميل يوميا فيما اعلنت
سلطنه عمان خفضا باربعين الف برميل يوميا
كذلك اعلنت كازاخستان عن خفض طوعي
بانتاجها
الف برميل يوميا فيما اعلنت الجابون عن
خفض بثمانيه الاف برميل يوميا وفي موسكو
اعلن نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسيه
ان بلاده ستمدد خفضا طوعيا بانتاجها من
النفط بواقع 500 الف برميل يوميا حتى
نهايه العمل جاري من متوسط مستوى الانتاج
وفقا لتقييمات مصادر ثانويه لشهر فبراير
وسيضاف هذا الخفض الى الخفض الذي اعلنه
تحالف اوبيكلاس في اكتوبر 2022 والذي قضى
بخفض بمليوني برميل يوميا حتى نهايه العام
الجاري هذا وكانت اسعار النفط قد تراجعت
الشهر الماضي الى ادنى مستوى لها في 15
شهرا بالقرب من 70 دولار للبرميل وفى ازمه
المصارف الامريكيه وتدخل الحكومه
السويسريه لانقاذ كريدي سويس العربيه
اذا مشاهدينا هذه التخفيضات هي التخفيضات
استباقيه احترازيه من قبل بلس لماذا
تحدثنا في التقرير عن الضبابيه المشهد
الاقتصادي الكلي بشكل عام والذي تازم اكثر
بسبب الازمه المصرفيه خلال الاسابيع
القليله الماضيه ما ولد ضبابيه وحاله عدم
يقين في الاقتصاد الكلي وفي الاسواق
تحديدا او الشعور العام هو الذي تاثر بشكل
كبير ليست اساسيات السوق النفطيه من حيث
المعروض ام الطلب وهذا ما استدعى تدخلا من
قبل اوبك بشكل احترازي واستباقي لاعاده
توجيه السوق لاعطاء السوق الارشاد الذي
يحتاجه خلال الفتره المقبله خاصه مشاهدينا
بان الشعور العام لدى المستثمرين اثر بشكل
كبير على الاسعار النفطيه بشكل تقلبات ليس
المهم هو مستوى السعر ولكن
الحد من التقلبات السعريه التي شهدناها
على مدار الاشهر الماضيه وتحديدا في
الاسابيع الاخيره هذا خام برنت واداءه
خلال شهر مارس انخفاضات بخمسه في المئه
كنا بمستويات تقريبا 85 او 86 دولار في
الاسبوع الاول من مارس انخفضنا الى
السبعين دولار ومن ثم ارتددنا هذا نايميكس
ماذا عن اداء الربعي لبرانت لاحظوا
التقلبات الحاده فيها من مستويات عند 86
87 دولار وحتى 88 دولار بدايه شهر
فبراير لمستويات طبعا شهدناها تنخفض الى
السبعين دولار اذا المضاربون كانوا
يحاولون
الكسب وزياده ايراداتهم هم يستفيدون من
التقلبات السعريه لكن هذه التقلبات مضره
بالاقتصاد العالمي مضره بالمنتجين مضره
بالمستهلكين وهذا ما استدعى التدخل اوبك
بلس لدعم
استقرار السوق وفي لقاء سابق خلال اليوم
تحدث نايف الدندني خبير في استراتيجيات
الطاقه حول تفاصيل قرار روسيا تحديدا
بتمديد خفض انتاجها المعلن سابقا في
فبراير والباله 500 الف برميل يوميا
تمديده حتى نهايه العام كما تحدث حول
اهميه توقيت قرار خفض التوعي في انتاج
النفط
اذا تذكر ناصر يمكن بلقائنا الاخير كنا
نتكلم عن نقطتين مهمات يعني احنا في
اللقاء كنا نتكلم عن موضوع روسيا وكيف انه
روسيا حتى مع اعلانها في فبراير الماضي
بتخفيض نص مليون برميل يوميا على اساس انه
ياخذ حيز التنفيذ في مارس ما اثر لاسباب
كثيره طبعا لسبب انه استهلاك المحلي
الروسي قل وبالتالي روسيا اضافت
الخفض في الاستهلاك المحلي الى باقه
انتاجها في الاسواق العالميه وبالتالي
روسيا اعلانها لخمس مئه الف برميل في مارس
الحقيقه ما كان مؤثر ولم ياتي يعني حتى
بما يعني بالنتيجه التي تريدها روسيا
نفسها هذا سبب سبب ثاني
امتناع الاداره الامريكيه ايضا عن انه
يعني حتى شراء من
انشاء النفط حتى تعبي مخزوناتها
الاستراتيجيه هذا اعطاء ان هناك من يحاول
ان يفعل او او يضغط على الاسواق بشكل كبير
وهذا الحقيقه امتناحه عن ملء الاس بي ارز
او المخزونات الاستراتيجيه
مؤشر لما تستهدف الاداره الامريكيه في
موضوع الاسواق في النفط سبب ثالث احنا في
ضبابيه عاليه مثل ما تكلمنا حتى في اللقاء
الاخير لانه ما في احد قادر يتنبه لا في
الانتر ستريتس ولا في موضوع الازمه
المصرفيه
والمشهد ضبابي في انفصال ما بين السوق
النفطيه
الماديه وسوق
التداولات الورق
نعم ففي انفصال كبير واحنا شفنا الحين
الديسك تو هذا الانفصال جالس يضغط على
الاسعار بشكل هائل في الدول في اوبك بلس
لا تستطيع ان تتحمل مثل هذا لفتره طويله
خصوصا انه السوق المادي
بموضوع الطلب ما في تهديد حقيقي على
الطالب ولا في زياده في العرض فبالتالي
هذا سيجلب يعني سيعزز الاتصال اكثر ما بين
السوق الماديه والسوق يعني انت ذكرتها
نايف يعني هناك
ارتباك في السوق
والمتمثل في التقلب الحاد في اسعار النفط
المستفيد منه بشكل اكبر هم المضاربون في
اسواق النفط وكنا قد سمعنا سابقا تحذيرات
من وزير الطاقه السعودي بانه على
المضاربين ان ينتبهوا وان اوبك بلس
والسعوديه دائما مستعدين لمفاجاه هؤلاء
بقرارات
تثنيهم عن هذه المضاربه التي تضر باستقرار
السوق النفطيه التي تضر بمصلحه المنتجين
والمستهلكين على حد سواء الى اي درجه
تعتقد بانه عنصر المفاجاه حاضر بقوه في
قرار اليوم
والله يعني هذا اثبات اضافي الحقيقه اللي
ما هو مؤكد في في
تصريحات اسمه وزير الطاقه السعودي
سمو ذكر في اكثر من مره انه لا احد يستطيع
ان يتنبا بما قد نفعله ومن يعني من يعتقد
انه قد يقرا يعني ما قد يعني نقرره فهو
مخطئ والحقيقه هذا اثبات اللي بقوله سمو
وزير الطاقه الحقيقيه كان عنصر المفاجاه
كبير
وتوقيته الحقيقه في مرحله حرجه ومرحله
فيها ضبابيه عاليه والمفترض انه هذه
القرار سياتي يعني
باستقرار اكبر
النفط بعد ما تفتتح الاسواق عن انتظرها
يوم يوم غد المفترض انه تفتح الاسواق
على هذه الاخبار من ثمان دول التخفيضات
هائله بمعدل 1.6
[موسيقى]
في الحقيقه هو توقيت او القرار يتخذ اليوم
من بلس طبعا هو متوقع انه يعلن عنه غدا في
الاجتماع اللجنه واقابيه هو قرار خلينا
نقول احتياطي او انه احترازي اتخذ من
المجموعه ككل من دول التحالف واعتقد انه
سيعطي خلينا نقول اللي هو اجراءات
احترازيه يعني كان هنالك في مع بدايه
العام 2023 ازمه حاله عدم العقيده ارتفعت
مع
الهويه اللي هو البنوك الفدرالي خصوصا
الفدراري الامريكي في الاستماع في رفع نسب
الفائده اللي هو الاستهداف التضخم يكون
عند الاثنين بالمئه فهذه طبعا شفنا ازمه
البنوك اللي حصلت وفي حتى في لقاء مع
العربيه قبل اسبوعين كان هنالك في توقعات
مننا انه نتوقع انه قد يكون هنالك في
تخفيضات تتخذها المجموعه وهذا ما شاهدناه
لليوم فانا اعتقد ان هذه الجواز ستعطي
خلينا نقول اللي هو حمايه بانه هو خلينا
نقول ارضيه ان الاسعار ما يكون في نوع من
الدعم بحيث انه
المتوقع ان تدراه
البنكيه تستمر في رفع اسعار الفائده يعني
ما نتوقع انه يخفضه من الان حتى يمكن
العام 2020 فاعتقد هذه التخفيضات اللي
اتخذتها اليوم المجموعه ستعطي نوع من
الدعم بما يواجهه اللي هي ازمه البنوك
والازمه الاقتصاديه الحاليه في كمان هنا
مساله مهمه يعني انا لاحظتها انه
التخفيضات التوعيه بالعاده كانت تتخذها
المملكه العربيه السعوديه فهنا اعتقد ان
في دور جدا مهم لعبته المملكه ان جميع
الدول
ساهمت في هذه التخفيضات من المملكه من
الامارات الكويت وايضا في الحقيقه الدول
من خارج دول الخليج فاعتقد هذا جدا مهم
لعبته المملكه العربيه السعوديه ان يكون
هنالك في تخفيضات طوعيه اضافيه من جميع
المنتجين المهمين وهذا يدل ان ان التحالف
ككل تحالف متماسك وله رؤيه موحده ضمن على
الازمه اللي يواجهها الاسواق في هذه الحال
في هذا العام
في هذا المشاهدين نصل الى نهايه فقرتنا
الخاصه لتغطيه قرارات خفض انتاج النفط من
دول الاوبك بلس نعود الان من جديد الى
زميل طاهر
[موسيقى]
شكرا لناصر فقدت صحيفه علامه التوثيق
الزرقاء الخاصه بها على منصه تويتر بعد
امتناعها عن دفع اي مستحقات ماليه ورسوم
شهريه الى تويتر مقابل علامه التوثيق
والتحقق على منصتها جاء ذلك بعدما اعلن
ايلون ماسك ان حسابات كثيره ستفقد علامه
توثيق الخاصه بها بدءا من الاول من ابريل
اذا لم تدفع الرسوم المقرره
[موسيقى]
تماشيا مع الخطه التشغيليه لرئاسه شؤون
الحرمين تنطلق مبادره لخدمه ضيوف الرحمن
وذلك من خلال توفير عدد من الروبوتات جنبا
الى جنب مع الجهود الانسانيه بهدف تسهيل
اداء العمره والروبوتات هذه تعمل على عدد
من الخدمات من اهمها الترجمه وتوجيه
المعتمرين والمصلين والاجابه على اسئله
الفتاوى
من مكه المكرمه مراسل العربيه اسامه
القاسم اهلا بك معنا اسامه الاجواء عندك
وكيف تسير يعني اكثر طبيعه هذه المبادره
اهلا وسهلا طاهر تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع
مشاهدين العربيه نعم انقل لكم صوت وصوره
اليوم من هنا من المطاف طبعا بالتاكيد هذه
الخدمات تاتي ضمن الخطه التشغيليه لرئاسه
شؤون الحرمين التي تعني بالاهتمام بالزوار
والمعتمرين طبعا الرئاسه اعلنت الامس عن
وصول 9.4 مليون زائر ومعتمر خلال العشر
الاولى من شهر رمضان المبارك وتوقعت ايضا
بان تتضاعف هذه الاعداد في الايام القادمه
وتحديدا في العشر الاواخر هذه تقدمها
رئاسه الحرمين بالاضافه الى الشراكه مع
عدد من الجهات بالتاكيد انها حديث اليوم
الذي سنتحدث عنه بشكل اوسع طبعا خدمه
الروبوتات هي خدمه جديده في الحرم المكي
وتحديدا في ساحه المطاف وايضا المطاف
العلوي وجهه الكبريه ماذا تعمل هذه
الروبوتات اولا هي تترجم للزوار
والمعتمرين ايضا تقدم الهدايا تترجم لهم
تربطهم بالمشائخ عن بعد ايضا الفتاوى
وبنفس الوقت ايضا تعقم وتطهر وتوجه الزوار
والمعتمرين الى الاماكن التي الان ليست
موجوده بحكم اننا الان انتهوا من صلاه
التراويح وبالتالي هم يبعدونها لكي لا
تسبب ازدحام
حركه الزوار والمعتمرين بحديثنا ايضا عن
الخدمات من الجدير بالذكر ان حدث ايضا عن
خدمات الاخرى كسوق زمزم 12 مليون لتر تم
يعني اعطائها للزوار المعتمرين خلال العشر
ايام اولى ايضا هناك عدد من الخدمات توفير
عدد من المعارض الحيه التي تعطي صوره
كبيره جدا عن الحرم المكي الشريف وتاريخ
مكه ومنها معرض الكسوه انقلكم الان في
صوره ايضا
لحركه المطاف وهي حركه تشهد الان امتلاء
طاهر اليوم حنا لما نتكلم عن خدمات
بالتاكيد الخدمات الكثير ليس عني ذكرها
الان ولكن هناك خدمات كثيره جدا من ناحيه
الحركه الكوادر الامنيه المدنيه التي
تتواجد
في اكثر من 121 بوابه بها اكثر من كادر
امني مدني وايضا اكثر من مترجم بست لغات
لتوجيه الزوار والمعتمرين ايضا التعقيم
والتطهير والتطهير مفارش المسجد الحرام
وايضا سقي زمزم التي تاتي متكعه مدار
الساعه كل هذه الخدمات واكثر لان يعيش
الزائر المعتمر تجربه في ساحات المسجد
الحرام ومداخله ومخارجه تجربه لا تقل عن
كونها ترتبط ايضا بادائه فريضه العمره كل
هذه الخدمات واكثر بالتاكيد انها ستكون
مضاعفه خلال الايام القادمه بالتزامن مع
زياده والزوار والمعتمرين شكرا جزيلا على
هذه الافاده اسامه القاسم مراسل العربيه
من مكه المكرمه تحياتي اليك
سوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من باريس التي
يصوت سكانها في استفتاء على ما اذا كان
سيتم سماح او الحذر للسكوتر الالكتروني في
شوارع العاصمه هذا الشخص ذهب للتصويت
ورسالته كانت واضحه نريد سكوتر هناك نحو
خمسه عشر الف سكوتر الكتروني في شوارع
باريس لكن المسؤولين متخوفون من الاستخدام
المتهور له
في تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 اللغه
الانجليزيه تحط من قدر اللغه الايطاليه
وتهينها هذه الكلمات التي تتضمنها مسوده
تشريع جديد بالبرلمان الايطالي قدموا قدمه
حزب رئيسه الوزراء جورجيا ميلوني من اجل
منع اي كلمات باللغه الانجليزيه او
الاجنبيه في الاتصالات الرسميه بايطاليا
وبحسب التشريع الجديد ستصل غرامه
المخالفين الى نحو 100 الف يورو ولكن برغم
ان التشريع يشكل جميع اللغات الاجنبيه
لكنه موجه بشكل خاص الى استخدام الكلمات
الانجليزيه المسوده تشير الى ان استخدام
الانجليزيه سيكون امرا اسوا من بقيه
اللغات لان بريطانيا لم تعد جزءا من
الاتحاد الاوروبي
فيديو اليوم في العربيه 360 من العراق حيث
اتيتو واحد من اقدم الاحتفالات في العالم
التي تقام بدايه ابريل من كل عام وهو
احتمال احتفال براس السنه الاشوريه
الجديده والذي يستمر لثني عشر يوما
العراقيون احيوا احتفال هذا العام
برقص الدبكه
[موسيقى]
نختم من بلد الحضارات والثقافات ونتابع
بعض صهيب سراير الان
واخبار الساعه صهيب مساء الخير مجددا الله
يعينك من نصره لنصره ومن مساء الخير هي
نفس الفتره المسائيه طبعا نفس الفتره مساء
الخير طاهر مره اخرى طبعا اخبار الساعه
كالعاده جوله سريعه شامله ومتنوعه في
اخبار في ختام هذه الفتره الاخباريه
المسائيه على العربيه في الصداره سنتابع
الوضع في نيويورك التي تتحضر لمظاهرات
مرتقبه لانصار ترامب مع مثوله امام
القاضيه ومثل شكرا